I'm sure you all can imagine
to treat it is to be introduced by
somebody whom you've known for 30 years
and very closely it's very sweet so I'm
delighted to be here very pleased to see
so many of you back this of course is a
very special day for intervention
mr. Qaddafi was killed this morning
under typically gruesome circumstances
as such things will go but to me there
were two iconic media events one was on
NBC and there they showed some
celebrating NTC rebels now the future
army or government of Libya and of
course as as rebels do in many parts of
the world they were shooting their guns
off in the air as part of celebration
and one guy walks up with a very long
look like a 30 caliber machine gun and
he gets in front of the NBC cameraman
you can see him posing lifts up the gun
pulls the trigger and nothing happens he
couldn't get the gun to work so he puts
it down a bunch of his fellows come and
they all gather around trying to get the
gun to work to me that was emblematic of
these rebels that's what implemented
part of it the second however was
another shot and this is of the guy who
may we don't know the full story
actually have participated in the
execution of mr. Gaddafi he was the
young man who got a hold of the Golden
Gun and he was waving this revolver I
imagine is gold plated in the air and
the thing that was so interesting about
him about the globalized world we live
in he was wearing the New York Yankees
cap so we we live in a globalized world
in this way and this particular
rebellion this intervention is playing
out right in front of us in real time so
as as Paul just mentioned I want to
continue the story in last week's
lecture as Paul mentioned I noted that
there are very powerful arguments
against intervention that we can find in
John Stuart Mill's classic texts on non
intervention from 1859 and we've made a
few copies that were there that you
could pick up on the way out if you
would like and I argued that one can
extract from the million project three
sets of principles one of them was the
principle of national security the other
was the principle of humanitarian
protection and the third was the
principle of collective
self-determination and all of these
principles work in the million argument
and as I mentioned last week all of them
and especially the collective
self-determination principle works in
favor of non non intervention the way
that one can respect the identity of a
people is to allow them to work out the
own terms of their life amongst
themselves without outside interference
and on top of that intervening is
usually dangerous so the National
Security principle comes into play and
thirdly according to mill and one of his
more original arguments it usually does
much more harm than good it simply
creates another Civil War
another autocracy or an empire rather
than a new free government so that was
his warning but that's not the whole
essay if you've read the essay before or
if you read it and over the next week
you'll see that in this essay you know
wonderfully entitled a few words on
non-intervention most of the words are
on intervention in this essay and he's
talking about the circumstances under
which one should intervene and he has
two sets of reasons
one set of reasons override non
intervention that is that there are
ethical concerns that even though the
reasons for non intervention are there
are simply overpowering overwhelming
paramount he calls them and that's one
set of arguments for intervention and
those sets of concerns as I mentioned
today are largely ones of national
security and of humanitarian protection
which will override our otherwise
default principle of non intervention
but there are also some concerns that
our urge us to disregard the arguments
for non intervention because the key
assumptions that sustain non
intervention the duty especially to
spec's self-determination don't hold in
a particular circumstance the
circumstances of a nation meriting of
the respect of non-intervention don't
hold that I'm there talking about next
week when I talk about secession and
imperialism and what's wrong with them
with ronk and parallelism and this week
I want to talk about the overriding
concerns the national security concerns
and the humanitarian concerns that
should lead us to override
non-intervention I've I've I have four
it's way too many but for national
security concerns in our literature as
it's evolved some from mil some beyond
mil that suggest why one should override
non-intervention I'm gonna go over them
very briefly some have to do with
rescuing citizens ideological warfare
post just war reform of an aggressor and
lastly the global balance of power and
I've got two humanitarian concerns to
override one has to do with ending a
protracted civil war and the other has
to do with classic humanitarian
intervention and for that I'm going to
talk about Libya that's the the
character situation of today and mil
describes them in overriding terms these
are considerations paramount
that's his phrase from the essay that
override now like many liberals mil
dismisses without much attention some
arguments in favor of intervention to
promote territory or revenue he says in
order to have enhanced national power or
prestige or profits and however
prevalent those motives are in real
world history we know territory and
revenue or extraordinarily prevalent
mill doesn't really pursue them because
he regards them as lacking in moral
significance and what he's that is they
shouldn't be the driving motives or
they're not motors we can justify for
intervention and he's interested in
cases of just intervention that is one
that is ffp justifiable not the
historical record of imperialist
interventions in his view let me briefly
mention the national security ones he
says in the essay we must accept of
course
any case in which such assistance that
is the intervention is a measure of
legitimate self-defense legitimate
self-defense is a justification for
intervening in another country and in
our literature we have a number of such
cases put in front of us one of them of
course is citizen rescue and this is
these are ones I'm not going to talk
about but that'll be in what I hope will
someday if I write quickly be a book
it'll contain many of these and citizen
rescue is one and I'll be talking about
the dawn Pacifica affair in 1850 the
u.s. equivalent the intervention in
grace town Nicaragua in the 1854 two
early cases and then I'm going to spend
most of that section on in today talking
about why I find despite the many abuses
that have been associated with
interventions to rescue your citizens
the Entebbe one comes closest to a
justifiable one and that's because it
was so surgical and it was generally a
last resort many others of course or not
but I'm not going to talk about that
today but I'd be happy to ask to address
any questions you might have
I'm also gonna reject arguments to
intervene for the sake of shifting the
global balance of power and a number of
my colleagues in the field and including
a very good moral philosopher Richard
Miller have made some arguments that put
on the table the idea that shifting the
global balance of power would be an
ethically justifiable intervention and I
think there are many problems of that
any given shift in any country that
would actually tip the balance of power
in ways that were important for your
security is likely to be too big a
country that you can safely intervene in
that's going to be the essence of that
argument but there's some others to the
third that I'm also not going to talk
about is the dilemmas associated with
intervening in the course of a just
defensive war after you've got to the
border and whether you need to stop at
the border and can keep going milik mill
of course was worried about napoleon
they got rid of them but they sent him
too close to Elba he came back after
Waterloo st. Helena he also talks in
very informative ways about what should
happen in the u.s. south he's a strong
advocate of radical reconstruction
because he
otherwise the south would rebel again or
all of the blood that expended in the in
the freeing of African Americans would
be wasted so he's a very strong radical
reconstructionist our modern analogies
of this of course in our modern time our
post-war Germany and post-war Japan and
all I want to do in this section is
identify how difficult the intervention
in quotes that is the occupation of
Japan was from a moral point of view
it's not the case as I read the new
literature that one could simply have
promised them to keep the Emperor and
that have been an easy surrender that's
not what have happened in any
circumstance has been costly and I want
to identify those moral dilemmas but
what I do want to talk about today with
regard to security is one other of a
very interesting argument about
internationalized civil war I'm so
pleased to see John Gatos in the back of
the room so I'm gonna step on some of
his very well trod terrain and mill in
this few words essays that if you're in
an internationalized civil war a system
wide bore that is where for example one
ideological faction is waging war
against another ideological faction
across borders under those circumstances
if the other ideological faction not
your own is already intervening then you
are justified in intervening - in
response to it and what he brings out
examples of this he talks about the
following if and here I quote if this
country Great Britain on account of its
freedom should find itself menaced with
attack by a coalition of continental
despots it ought to consider the popular
party in every nation of the continent
as its natural Ally the Liberals should
be to it he says what the Protestants of
Europe were to the government of Queen
Elizabeth
so Protestants versus Catholics liberals
versus autocrats
he has in mind the 1830s and 40s of his
own time but Protestants versus
Catholics in that kind of a situation
where global
is fought by ideological factions across
borders a transnational civil war under
those circumstances if the other side is
intervening to prop up its guys you can
justifiably intervene to prop up yours
that's his argument that's it is it has
some logical claim to it but what I'm
trying to do is look into it a little
bit more deeply I'm not gonna talk about
the 1830s and 40s because it is much
more complicated than he portrays there
what I want to go back is to the
argument that would have appealed to so
many of his readers from this essay and
that is the kind of logic that existed
in some religious civil wars go back to
the sixteenth century that he's
referring to and we can find examples of
this I found an interesting quote from
Sir Nicholas Throckmorton who was
Elizabeth the first ambassador in France
in these in the 1560s and he advocated
intervention in support of fellow
Protestants by warning and I quote now
when the general design is to
exterminate all nations dissenting with
them in religion what will become of us
when the like professors with us shall
be destroyed in Flanders in France in
the 16th century professors weren't
folks like us professors for somebody
who professed the same thing there were
Co believers so he's worried if the
Catholics are doing in the Protestants
what's going to become of us not so much
by attacking England but by doing in the
Protestants of Europe that was Sir
Nicholas is concern it of course also
resonates as I implied in the logic of
the 20th century in the 20th century
cold war in the rhetoric of the Reagan
doctrine for example which pledged again
I quote we must not break faith with
those who are risking their lives on
every continent from Afghanistan to
Nicaragua to defy Soviet aggression and
secure rights which have been ours since
birth support for freedom fighters is
self-defense not state the essence of
the Reagan doctrine basically he's
adding a rollback in many years
next version to the traditional
containment of American post-war foreign
policy in practice the early Cold War
did witness a whole series of covert
actions by the US and Albania and China
and Soviet efforts to control local
communist parties in Europe and
elsewhere Reagan and Brezhnev we know
practiced their doctrines in Nicaragua
and Czechoslovakia respectively each of
them engaging in interventions but at
the same time seeing that as an ethical
model of the Cold War many of us have
come to see is much too crude and
dangerous because the exceptions were at
least as important to the success of the
Cold War on both sides the west support
for Tito Tito's Yugoslavia was very very
important and the East that is the
Soviet support for third world
nationalists was very important in the
global balance of power and not to speak
of the best of examples the effective
combination of east-west date on with
triangulation devised by the Nixon
administration to help exploit the
Chinese split from the Soviets in the
1970s so there's a lot of reasons not to
buy into the modern Cold War logic but
what I'd like to suggest is there are
also not reasons to buy into Mills
argument you know invoking that iconic
figure of British history Elizabeth the
Great and here I'm referring to a very
interesting event called the expedition
to New Haven now not this New Haven it
was a different New Haven the New Haven
that's being referred to is larve in
Normandy and France and what happened is
that during the polarizing civil wars as
Elizabeth learned from this New Haven
expedition which was a failure to have a
very different foreign policy that
followed it now in 1559 she intervened
to rollback the catholic threat I'm
using cold war language in Scotland she
sent troops to assist the more powerful
faction of the Scottish Protestant Lords
who were struggling against a regime
sustained by French forces when her more
radical advisors Throckmorton
others urged who urged who urged her to
do the same in France across the channel
she reluctantly agreed to send an
expedition to France to intervene in
France to support the Protestant Nobles
who were rebelling against their
Catholic King the expeditionary force
landed in New Haven
marv marched in to meet their putative
French allies they got on each other's
nerves very quickly quarrels broke out
the French Protestants very quickly
within just a couple of months defected
from the English Protestant expedition
they got a better deal promised to them
by their French Catholic monarch and
they just couldn't stand the idea of
Englishmen on French soil so the entire
expedition collapsed there were
relatively high casualties completely
wasted a large loss of treasure
she then developed a much more
sophisticated foreign policy whose basic
principles were the following - number
one she would only intervene where she
would be convinced was a vital necessity
and for her that meant Scotland and
Flanders it was seen as very important
to prevent the Catholic powers from
fully controlling Flanders Flanders was
the industrial heartland of 16th century
Europe having that controlled by one
hostile power would be to her
unacceptable but even then she would
only intervene in a secondary capacity
if she had strong local allies and this
was the doctrine that she developed she
further added to that a diplomacy that
played Catholic France off against
Catholic Spain to prevent them from
uniting against her a diplomacy that was
followed a century later by Cardinal
Richelieu among the Catholic powers who
wisely aligned with Protestant States as
a way to preserve the French national
monarchy and so consistent with this the
logic of an international civil war
doesn't really stand up even to the
examples that Mill puts in front of it
it's when you turn you and you move from
the abstract logic of counter
intervention to the reality of the
histories even the history that
himself was invoking it doesn't it
doesn't really sustain itself
for us I think the lesson there is one
of caution that however logical that may
sound the practical realities of
international history international
politics suggest that we should not
adopt that other than in the extreme
circumstances perhaps the kind of ones
that she was talking about so let me
then pass over again
the reconstruction issue and having
talked a bit about national security and
be more than willing to come back to any
of those examples in questions or answer
or to recommend it to you and the
eventual written version of all this let
me turn to what is the issues of another
circumstance for overriding and that's
humanitarian protection that is
intervening to save lives that is to
reduce harms to individuals and there
are two one two cases that mill brings
forward to us for humanitarian
protection and one of them the first of
them is what he calls a protracted civil
war that is when a civil war goes on for
a long time remember he's in favor of
the sides fighting out in civil wars
that's the way you self-determined you
fight to a conclusion that's his
position but if that civil war goes on
for time after time year after year
armies clashing and grinding the faces
of the poor the farmers the small the
workers in the cities if that's the
course of it then he says it becomes one
that needs to be overridden he says in
this case a protracted civil war in
which the contending parties are so
equally balanced that there is no
probability of a speedy issue or if
there is the victorious side cannot hope
to keep down the vanquished but by
severity x' repugnant to humanity and
injurious to the permanent welfare of
the country so some civil wars the ones
that just grind on and on without any
prospect of a ready victory are ones
that need to be stopped because of the
harm that they inflict upon ordinary
human beings non-combatants and others
he talks about of
radhiya circumstances in which one
should intervene one for the case of
ethnic civil wars he brings to mind the
Greeks and the Turks and also the case
of the Belgians and the and the Dutch
those I want to postpone to next week
when we talk about secession because for
them the solution is intervention with
partition the one I want to focus on
this week is the civil wars that are
fought over political motives political
ends who's going to rule call them
ideological civil wars the left the
right or just whoever gets control of
state power and there he talks about a
couple of them but the one that he has
he's most interested one in is one that
takes place in Portugal and there he
notices there are two factions that are
struggling okay to control one of them
of the Republican left and the other
minar Keable any notes that at one point
there occurred an equitable compromise
and it seemed to have produced good
results in Portugal that's all that he
says about it and this one now we can
look into Portugal at this point and see
a whole series of civil wars and then we
see with the rules of King Pedro from
1853 to 1861 and King Louis from 1861 to
1863 calms down a national government is
formed and it begins to re-enter into
the modern world with improvements for
the population before then it's civil
war so I kept wondering what exact
intervention did he have in mind it's
hard to be sure and I could certainly be
proven wrong but I spent a couple
summers ago a number of very pleasant
days at the University of Southampton
reading the Palmerston Spri vut papers
from the 1840s all of which are nicely
kept there and as after having finished
that my guess is that the intervention
that he has in mind took place in 1846
then as I had mentioned Portuguese
politics were radically split and there
was
if inviolable more than the generation
there were two groups one group calling
themselves the Chartist this was a
moderate quasi constitutional definitely
pro minar kacal group that happened to
be in power and the other group were
called the September and this was a
radical in favor of another Constitution
an earlier more radical constitution of
1822 beginning in the 1830s Britain had
supported the the more conservative
group aligned behind someone in Queen
Maria and her ministers were basically
monarchist within the shape of
conservative Constitution at this point
the September is the more radical
Republican styled group took up arms and
they then began to fight a rather
protracted civil war that attracted the
interest of Spain France and England
France and Spain were pressing perhaps
for intervention of for the sake of who
knows what
at this point Palmerston the Foreign
Secretary sent a Cornel Wilde who was a
special envoy and a secret envoy to
exercise what Palmerston in one of his
letters to him called a perspective of
force that was the phrase that he said
that was the mandate addressed to Cornel
Wilde and what this involved after Wilde
arrived in Portugal was pressuring both
factions the monarchist under Queen
Maria the Republicans at September's and
he pressured them to form a coalition
that is a mediated joint unified
government and he did so by mobilizing
some Spanish troops on land he called in
a British squadron to blast away at the
shore for a while sending a message that
they could improve the reign if there
wasn't better cooperation and when he
then basically isolated the September
around Oporto he put extreme pressure on
them this is wild persuading them to
join the government of Queen Maria and
lay down the rest of their claims
persuading Queen Maria to take away the
charges she had placed against the
September
and to modify the constitution in a more
Republican direction
a classic mediated compromise solution
and milk commented it looked ill at the
commencement again not referring to the
particular action but what I think is
this 1846 intervention but I continue
the quote it could be justified by the
event a really healing measure he called
it this was his endorsement of this
intervention it sounds like a nice story
when we look a little further however
there are some problems genuine
stability took a few more years perhaps
not surprisingly given the difficulties
of mediation and its decisive impetus
was rather than the weak compromise of
1846 it was more the the reforms as I
mentioned earlier that were launched by
the wise and very industrious King Pedro
who replaced his mother in 1853 he had a
very short reign he died of cholera in
1861 but he began to launch the real
reforms that made the country
reconcilable that is he was the one who
helped to create a genuine political
center amongst the various elite
factions and begun administrative
reforms that allowed Portugal to come
back on its feet launched an economic
development program which considered
which could the first modern roads and
railroads are built in Portugal and
Portugal then began its integration into
the modern European world that was part
of the good story the more difficult
part of the story is that having
intervened in 1846 England basically
stayed over the horizon regularly
meddling in Portuguese politics and in
the Portuguese Empire in ways that were
in the end quite resented by the
Portuguese government despite their
strong dependence upon Britain so hardly
a happy self-determination story but
arguably as Mill rout was right in 1859
for him a justifiable intervention I'll
draw some lessons from this in a moment
but I one thing that may be very curious
as I read through the documents was why
was this a secret special envoy said
number one it wasn't secret to the
Portuguese he showed up with all the
factions
the queenie pressured the september's it
wasn't secret to the british admiral
offshore he was taking instructions from
wild wasn't secret to the british
ambassador who was there who was also
taking instructions wasn't secret to the
spanish they were cooperating taking
wild suggestions the French quickly knew
about it the cabinet I found out knew
about it was a whi secret and it turns
out quite interesting the documents the
one person it was kept secret from was
Queen Victoria because she was pursuing
a separate diplomacy trying to prop up
Queen Maria there was sort of
monarchical solidarity and she was not
submitting her diplomatic letters to the
cabinet and Palmerston complained
repeatedly about the fact that this was
not quite a responsible government was
supposed to be if the Queen was running
her own foreign policy so that was the
one curiosity I found in the archives
but what are the lessons the two lessons
I think that are relevant from the
ethical point of view the political and
ethical point of view his armed
intervention may be justifiable in these
kind of a circumstances to halt a war a
protracted civil war but it's unlikely
to be sufficient additional measures
will be needed to make the intervention
stick to make it sustainable to make it
effective ideally those measures will be
domestic because it will have created a
circumstances of genuine self-rule but
if not some kind of a further
international presence may be needed and
otherwise if it's a quick surgical
intervention it may soon have to be
repeated if it doesn't acquire the kind
of roots that we in our modern
literature described as peace building
the second interval that comes from this
is that unilateral interventions even
well-meaning as potentially this one was
in 1846 very soon deteriorates become
corrupted by self-dealing kind of
motives and the British presence there
was certainly exploitative over time
making a case for multilateralism so
that's the first of the humanitarian
intervention stopping a protect
protracted Civil War let me now turn to
the one that we're thinking about most
today the classic you man
terian intervention that is the kind of
intervention that is designed to stop
the phrases run massacre a genocide may
be institutionalized slavery michael
waltzer another writer in this field
calls them drawing upon the classic
phrases the nut mills own massacres that
shocked the conscience of mankind so
here the case is different from a
protracted civil war in a protracted
civil war there are non combatant
casualties which are rendus as mill
mentioned there is no government that's
really in charge there are armies in a
ravaging the countryside here the
government is much too much in charge
and has launched a campaign of slaughter
against its own population as we see for
example in a genocide now in the
literature on humanitarian intervention
arguments have been made that the
intervener should have a morally
defensible mode of helping those who are
being slaughtered share the purpose of
ending the slaughter oh and have a a m--
to eventually help establish a
self-determining people this is it can't
just be an excuse for imperialism
furthermore there is a standard just
more arguments for last resort after
exploring peaceful resolution and it
should be a case that if it's gonna be
an ethically justifiable intervention it
should only take place in circumstances
under which it's likely to save more
lives than it costs you don't need a
ravine to save people and start World
War 3 to take the classic example of
that we know where we have these
concerns because we know that
humanitarian interventions have been
repeatedly exploited one can go down the
list of armed interventions in countries
that then turn out into ordinary old
imperialism from our 1898 intervention
in Cuba for example to the many many
others that we could list but we can
also find examples of the kind of
slaughters that could have motivated
an intervention
they're horrendous quality and some did
and some did not most of the big
examples are after Mills time mill
actually couldn't quite imagine this is
not a category he talks about couldn't
quite imagine what he calls a civilized
government engaging in these kinds of
slaughters he thought that that was
limited to other parts of the world that
we'll talk about next week
civilized governments he couldn't quite
imagine the 20th century history of
civilized governments and so the models
that would have justified interventions
in our time or things like the Holocaust
in 1971 in Bangladesh for example where
the government to Pakistan turned
against the people of East Pakistan
killed between 200 and 300 thousand and
generated about 6 million refugees and
there of course India did intervene
Cambodia where even though it's not a
genocide technically 1.8 1.9 million
people were killed in circumstances from
either direct slaughter to the creating
of circumstances under which they were
likely to to starve to death
Rwanda in our own time where there was
no real intervention other than by the
RPF one of the factions who came in to
try to stop it and then much too
belatedly and with mixed purposes the
French a Sudan in 2003 not later but
Sudan in 2003 there was a kind of a
slaughter that would have arguably
justified an intervention and now we
have in front of us today the question
of Libya you know beginning this past
spring so in Libya 2011 we some
questions to face is it legal as a
humanitarian intervention is it ethical
as a humanitarian intervention one thing
we know we think we know is that the
casualties experienced actually
experienced we're nowhere near the level
of past humanitarian interventions I
already mentioned Bangladesh 1971 200 to
300 thousand people killed of these
eight million refugees Rwanda 800,000
I've mentioned the other numbers
this motivated you know one of the great
philosophers who looked at these
questions Michael Walter in a recent
piece to say that Libya does not qualify
as a humanitarian intervention it's not
a massacre he said like Rwanda and
instead it's an ordinary old civil war a
rebellion against a tyrant and
unfortunately for the Libyans one that
was incapable of succeeding on its own
it should have been left to fight itself
out basically a classic million response
I agree with his comparison to Rwanda it
was certainly not Rwanda it wasn't the
kind of slaughter that historically have
justified unilateral interventions as a
matter of duty such as would be
generated for example by a genocide it's
not that at all but what I think Michael
misses and where I where I think I
disagree with him I haven't spoken to
him since he published the piece is that
something new has taken place and it's
something called the responsibility to
protect a new doctrine which has
significantly modified the standards of
humanitarian intervention I hope you all
have a copy of it it's a paragraphs 138
and 139 of a UN 2005 outcome document
and I suggest that there is a new norm
for intervention and that norm
authorized when it's authorized by the
Security Council can authorize
protection and it replaces the classic
massacre standard with something
different now we know that we have an
authorization from the United Nations
Security Council in its classic language
in resolution 1973 of March 17th of this
past spring it authorized UN
member-states quote-unquote to take all
necessary measures which means to use
force
I'm new here I'm sorry I don't that's
that's okay I'll resume he says in this
resolution another intervention yes this
this resolution authorizes member states
to take all necessary measures which in
UN language means use force to protect
civilians and civilian populated areas
in Libya by establishing a no-fly zone
enforcing an arms embargo against
Colonel Qaddafi the resolution gave
teeth to this much-heralded proposition
called the responsibility to protect
that you have in front of you the 2005
UN World Summit outcome document and it
says that there's a responsibility of
the international community if a local
home government fails to do so to
provide protection to help protect
populations from genocide war crimes
ethnic cleansing and crimes against
humanity those are the four elements of
the responsibility to protect this is
only the third time that this principle
has been invoked since it's 2005
instantiation in that General Assembly
resolution it was invoked in 2006 to
beef up the UN peacekeeping operation in
Darfur set up after the worst of the
massacres in Darfur were over and it
nonetheless still failed to provide real
protection but this doctrine was cited
in UN Security Council resolution 1706
the second case that it was used for
chapter 7 enforcement purposes was just
a couple weeks before 1973 another
resolution that set up sanctions
financial sanctions against Gaddafi's
regime it was when these were not
working that a couple of weeks later
that the Security Council resolution
1973 as just mentioned authorized the
use of force against the government of
against against the government of
Colonel Qadhafi for the sake of
protecting civilians none in in
in in Libya it's very important because
this new doctrine was designed to bridge
the gaps between legality and legitimacy
and provide a framework that would be
internationally sanctioned for the
protection of civilians in circumstances
in which their own governments were not
doing so so let me make a couple of
comments about legality legitimacy and
then conclude with some comments on
outcomes and lessons from the Libyan
experience if we look at that outcome
document that's right in front of you
looking let's first look at legality is
that articulated r2p responsibility to
protect its a General Assembly
resolution it's a unanimous General
Assembly resolution every member state
of the UN in 1992 that would have been a
192 I guess have signed on to that
document they've all basically ascribed
to it it's the unanimous declaration but
it's a General Assembly resolution a
General Assembly resolution is only a
recommendation it is not
quasi-legislative or legislative in
international law it is only an
expression of opinion of what should be
done not what states have pledged by law
that they will do and it's for that
reason that Nicaraguan Foreign Minister
Miguel Mikoto Brockman described the
resolution as not having legal force
cannot be considered as a binding source
of international law under the terms of
international law and article 38 of the
statute of the International Court that
describes what is international law a
General Assembly resolution is not and
so he representing the garage WA
pushed back against the idea of this new
norm of r2p but it's not quite as
straightforward as former father
descoteaux bruckman he's a Jesuit priest
who was defrocked by the Pope at one
point or another and then went on to a
distinguished career in diplomacy there
there are there is afterlife in this
world it's not quite as straightforward
for a couple reasons one is that one
element of r2p genocide is well
established international law the
Genocide Convention is if anything the
single strongest legal norm in the
international panoply with regard to
protection in the use of force the
convention requires all states to
prevent and punish genocide it leaves
the interpretation to the International
Court of Justice in article 9 and
enforcement to the Security Council in
article 8 but it's clearly a
well-established norm stopping genocide
in their national law the other part
that's a little different from what mr.
Miguel disco de Brockman said is that
the Security Council has claimed very
wide discretion for its mandate under
Chapter 7 it has the authority to make
binding resolutions that bind on all
states in matters of international peace
and security
it's a legal body therefore whose
resolutions have legal binding character
to it and moreover it's a political body
it's a political body whose discretion
is unbound in article 39 to decide based
on its own judgment what constitutes
threats to peace breaches the peace and
acts of aggression Security Council has
great international authority according
to the UN Charter and if we look at its
record its record is one of the very
wide use of that Authority if we look at
its record under Chapter 7 writing
enforcement resolutions there are
resolutions that employed sanctions on
Rhodesia and South Africa connected with
both massive violence and apartheid
military buildup patterns of aggression
they include enforcement resolutions
with regard to genocide ethnic cleansing
and war crimes in the former Yugoslavia
in the 90s interference with the
delivery of humanitarian supplies also
was written under Chapter 7 violations
of ceasefires in civil wars and even
coos against democratic governments as
in Haiti
inspired Chapter seven authoritative
binding resolutions to enforce outcomes
on States therefore reading a very very
broad mandates to itself thus the
legality of r2p is contestable it's
clearly what you have in front of you is
not the equivalent of a treaty not at
all
on the other hand the Security Council
has operated in a very broad scope and
so by then endorsing r2p
as it did in a later Security Council
resolution it's announcing that its own
discretion will include taking to
account these concerns
that's not law either but it does say
that a body that has the authority to
impose binding obligations is going to
use these as part of its criteria if it
sounds murky it is but it's a
high-powered norm not yet clear
absolutely clear law but one that in the
past has been deferred to when Security
Council has exercised it let's move to
legitimacy legitimacy of the r2p
doctrine here I mean how its received by
the community of states the Kosovo
crisis was a watershed event in the
reformulation
of the doctrine of humanitarian
intervention and indeed the NATO States
intervened you know in a famous
Commission report that I'll describe in
a moment it was declared to be illegal
because Security Council did not
authorize the intervention but
legitimate in the phrases of of Judge
Goldstone but soon after the Kosovo
intervention the developing States the
g77 100 despite the 77 this is the UN
there 132 of them but they don't call
them not call the G 132 they condemned
in a unanimous declaration the so-called
right of humanitarian intervention in
paragraph 69 of their ministerial
declaration of 24 September 1999 three
months after the NATO intervention into
Kosovo
so the developing countries made clear
they're not buying anything with regard
manatorian intervention a commission was
set up then under Judge Goldstone to try
to come to a more objective look at what
happened in Kosovo to try to come to a
judgement of it and Goldstone recruited
a whole group of academics former
politicians and diplomats and they
developed a report from all over the
world and they developed a report that
identified threshold principles for when
an intervention would be justified the
first of these are severe violations of
international human rights or
humanitarian law subjection of a
civilian society I'm quoting to great
suffering and risk due to the failure of
the state that entails a breakdown of
governments at the level of the
territorial sovereign state so a lot of
violations of humanitarian law a lot of
suffering whether inflicted by a state
or just because the state is broken down
now needless to say this is pretty fuzzy
and it's very wide if that's the
threshold principle for intervention
when they considered who could authorize
it they said okay the Security Council
would be the best but if these are the
circumstances somebody should do
something so we got a very wide license
that the Kosovo Commission is endorsing
not noticeably as wide as Security
Council practice in the 1990s when they
were intervening for anything and
everything that they could put together
majority for but nonetheless this is
very wide standards human rights human
suffering etc this produced a great deal
of debate needless to say
Kofi Annan realizing that this the
Kosovo Commission was not going to
resolve this issue
think of what the g77 had already said
just a few months before a commission to
friends of his Mohamed Sanu new and
Gareth Evans the former foreign
ministers of Algeria and Australia
respectively to chair a commission that
was funded by the Government of Canada
the International Commission on
intervention and state sovereignty they
get they're covering their bases
intervention and state sovereignty I see
i SS to investigate the circumstances of
when an intervention would be legitimate
what they did in a very interesting
report is they narrowed the triggers for
a justifiable intervention in this
legitimate term
- just large-scale loss of life and
large-scale ethnic cleansing so they're
you know let's this is narrowing
compared to human rights and suffering
when either by the action or inaction of
states when it comes to Authority they
they fulsomely say that the right
Authority is the Security Council but
they go on to say in shocking uncoding
and shocking situations concerned States
may not rule out other measures which
means not always Security Council well
uh none welcome that report in May of
2001 I was working for him at that point
he said to me you know Michael let's
arrange a big meeting to brief this
report in the UN so I go off to the
president the General Assembly and I'd
say I'd like to have the ECOSOC room a
little used a great big nice room to
present the report and let's have it dis
debated and discussed among the
membership the president the GA turned
back to me says no way this is not UN
doctrine and we are not going to stir up
the equivalent of a diplomatic riot by
presenting this in an official capacity
so I had to go across the street and
with Canadian money we booked the
millennium Plaza Ballroom and some noon
and Evans presented the report there to
a quite a heated debate so it could not
even be discussed within a UN building
in May of 2001 it's a sign of the really
hard work and the diplomatic skill of
Evans and staff noon that just for in a
bit years later you have those two
paragraphs in front of you these are
unanimous statements from the entire
membership of the UN in an endorsing r2p
but notice how it's different and it's
very important that's the reason I Xerox
that copy to you number one they further
narrowed the triggers very carefully
they went from Human Rights Kosovo
Commission to large-scale human
casualties the ICW is to four elements
of r2p genocide war crimes ethnic
cleansing and crimes against humanity
notice this is a
much narrower set of triggers than what
we described before and all of these
have international legal significance
ethnic cleansing after the ICTY trials
crimes against humanity is well
established within international
criminal law genocide and war crimes -
and notice in case anybody was hard of
hearing in the international community I
think I underlined it I don't know if
the underline show up look how many
times they thought it was necessary to
repeat exactly those four elements in
the paragraphs as if any hard-of-hearing
folks thought that there would be other
circumstances that would justify an
intervention I think it's five times in
those paragraphs it is rhetorically
ridiculous but politically significant
that they thought they had to say those
four phrases
so those four phrases five times in a
single paragraph the other significant
transformation that you'll see is that
there is no ambiguity whatsoever
only when endorsed by the Security
Council and under those terms the
membership could sign on to those two
paragraphs 138 and 139 let me briefly
then talk about practice because here we
had the doctrine in 2005 how would we be
applied was just as significant and the
most important thing that took place the
first test case of it other than using
it to bless the Sudan operation but
totally and effectively but no and no
one knew then we thought it would have
any consequence but the first real test
case of this doctrine was Burma that is
Myanmar cyclone nargis in Burma in 2008
after this cyclone hurricane struck the
Burmese government was totally
ineffective in providing aid to a large
hunk of their population particularly
population on the coast people lacked
clean water medical supplies running out
of food very severe suffering was taking
place bernard Koosh nair the inimitable
love foreign minister and activist of
france and Gareth Evans both went before
the press saying this is an art
a situation the international community
has a responsibility to act to rescue
the Burmese population from this
impending catastrophe the lack of clean
water the lack of medicine the
increasing shortage of food but what
happened here was that there was
immediate pushback from the
secretary-general and from some key
other members I own the Security Council
and from Gareth Evans once he was
approached he pulled back from his
statement this has no it's more
complicated than that
and from the standpoint of the UN
membership I haven't asked the Burmese
what they thought of it it was the
exactly the right thing to do to enhance
the legitimacy of r2p because even
though it was absolutely true that the
government was totally ineffective and
assisting its own citizens and people
were suffering those were the standards
of the I CI SS and of the Kosovo report
not the standards of RTP the standards
of r2p repeated five times where
genocide ethnic cleansing crimes against
humanity and war crimes and crimes
against humanity being the closest to
that but the the elements of the crime
of crimes against humanity do talk about
questions like murder extermination
enslavement and widespread or systematic
attacks in the civilian population but
they have to be part of a government
policy a consistent plan and no one
could provide evidence that the snork
the government of Burma was planning for
their citizens to starve died of disease
lack medical care and it's with that
push back that nothing was done could
diplomacy from Singapore and others
eventually opened up the country to
assistance but a few weeks late but by
doing that by not acting the legitimacy
of this norm was suddenly reinforced
very strongly for the g77 developing
countries they had fought hard to have
it narrow the narrowness looked to them
as if it would work and again in two
later cases Kenyatta in 2008 Guinea in
2009 in both cases there was discussion
by some states that it was an r2p
situation but in neither case did the UN
or the Security Council invoke it
my former boss Kofi Annan went to
mediate the crisis in Kenya he was very
careful not to use the words in public
this was not an RTP situation but he
knew very well that the government of
Kenya was hearing about r2p from other
African states other states and they
knew that they were bargaining under the
shadow of r2p
that is if they did nothing or began to
engage in crimes against humanity some
of which were occurring under those
circumstances they might face
international sanctions but it wasn't
explicitly used but it did make the
bargaining much more effective and the
same thing happened I won't go into it
in Guinea in 2009 that brings us to
Libya this is now the most important
test case and here's where I'll wrap up
what the resolution authorized to take
all necessary measures classic language
authorizing the use of force to protect
civilians and civilian populated areas
here we marry legality we have a UN
Security Council resolution authorizing
force and legitimacy drawing upon now
the principles of r2p it's at this
rating of course much too early to get a
sense of the long term implications of
all of this but what we nonetheless
eveson claims in front of us if we look
on the justification side we had
President Obama's March 28th speech and
a variety of others and he made the case
for the intervention in this speech and
he stressed three things in increasing
order of prominence and importance one
was a threat to regional stability it
could upset the ongoing revolutions in
Egypt and Tunisia notice he's also here
talking about the international
dimensions of the Libyan crisis which
which which puts it back in the
framework of international threats to
peace and security which is the chapter7
language but clearly this was these were
throwaway lines for him what's more
important of course was what he called
Gaddafi's extreme violence and he went
on the documented launching jets and
helicopters against civilians the
cut-off of water for tens of thousands
including the town of Misurata cities
and towns shelled gun ships Unleashed
homes raided hospitals raided arbitrary
arrests torture and the specific
of rapes all of which there was evidence
for and led to the indictment before the
ICC that was launched at the same time
but that was not the real driver
you probably remember what the real
driver was for the president when he was
trying to make the case for intervention
and it was the threat of worse to come
it was like Kosovo it was the threat not
what had happened but was was it is
viewed likely to happen was his argument
and it was the looming threat to
Benghazi where the president said we
could not wait one more day a town of
700,000 people he said he helpfully then
said the size of Charlotte and for most
non North Carolinians that didn't help
much but the 700,000 told us something
and he said Qadhafi had said there'll be
no mercy in quotation marks and they
would be hunted down but like rats that
was the claim and the president said at
that point one could not wait there was
no time to wait action was necessary and
following a course behind the British
and the French he went to the Security
Council following behind the British in
the French and was able to persuade the
council to vote on this with ten votes
in favor no vetoes but abstentions from
Russia China India and Brazil so
nonetheless it passed as a legal
resolution the problem is that now we
know having had some time the Red Cross
has done surveys the Red Cross so far
has only counted found 3,500 bodies
that's not 700,000 hundreds in towns
that were subject to attack not the
thousands that people in March were
thinking about now the government the
NTC claims that there are thirty to
fifty thousand people that have died but
they haven't been found yet and we don't
know whether they will they might be
there just in the middle of a civil war
you got better things to do then hunt
over potential cemeteries but still the
key argument that the president made was
the threat not the body count and we
have to ask ourselves should we have
preferred that he waited until we could
have a documented 30 to 50 thousand
before we act or was he right as he
claimed he was right to act to prevent
the deaths of
250-thousand which was his claim so it's
a hard issue
we won't know but the question is should
we have waited and for him of course the
answer was no many would argue that
protection is better than regret but
this will be challenged and we'll see
what comes of it let me wrap up with two
comments what about the positive of r2p
and then another about the negative or
at least a concern that is arisen the
positive part of r2p at least for me is
that r2p
and the libya president precedent has
solved the genocide problem so what do I
mean by that ridiculous statement by
that I do not mean that future genocides
have been prevented that's not going
there's you need political will but what
I do mean is that by the new standards
of r2p we've precluded what I would call
the genocide trap the G trap the G word
trap as the threshold for legitimate
protection Darfurians for example in
2003 went through a series of massive
slaughters while an international
commission of highly able scholars the
International Commission of Inquiry on
Darfur JH of the UN secretary-general
engage in very extensive really expert
research they interviewed they did
documentary work and a year later they
reported back there was no genocide in
Darfur because you could not establish
mens rea ax that is you could not
establish that
Basheer's motive for unleashing the
Janjaweed on the people of Darfur was to
kill them because they were Darfurians
because they were darker because they
were part of a different religious or
other faction couldn't prove that
instead they did document tens maybe
hundreds of thousands of deaths
arbitrarily inflicted on a victimized
population in 2003 and 2004 the story
after she doesn't five much more
complicated it's a civil war but before
then this was crimes against humanity
and well documented in suction this
report but because they spent a year
working over the genocide question
Darfurians died in large numbers the
you of r2p is that we now have a new set
of standards that are more let's call
them realistic in the best sense of that
word realistic and tapping into the kind
of suffering that people face that now
are operative that are different from
the old humanitarian standards that
Michael Walzer invoked when he invoked
Rwanda and massacres that shocked the
conscience of mankind we have a new set
of standards and those standards are
ethnic cleansing war crimes crimes
against humanity and genocide so the new
standards are higher much higher than
the Security Council practice of the 90s
that terrified the g77 the developing
countries concerned about multilateral
imperialism much higher than that and
there are also much higher excuse me
much higher than the standards of the
Kosovo commission any human rights
violations or the IC SS satisfying again
the concerns of the g77 but they are
much lower than just using genocide as
the standard so we have lowered the
standards from genocide lowered the
standards at Michael Walter would see
raised them from the standards that
terrified the the g77 and we have made
this shift in the context of raising the
multi authorisation standards that is
we've made it clear as they have made it
clear that you need to have a Security
Council authorization in order to use
these standards that are lower than the
genocide standards that have
historically justified a unilateral
intervention that is a very interesting
normative shift that has taken place and
is the result of of the Libya episode
okay and I think to my mind at least
this is reasonable this should we have a
shift of substantive standards that move
them down balanced by down from genocide
by an increase in procedural standards
that have moved up and I think that's a
relatively sensible balance that's been
achieved so to me that's the positive
part the negative is that RTP has been
severely wounded by
by Livia by the Libya episode to gain
approval you know I mentioned already
there was a vote for it but it was not
fulsome it was quite close there were
ten votes in favor five abstentions as I
mentioned Brazil China Germany India and
Russia Brazil Germany and India
significally are seeking permanent
membership on Security Council these
will be the new much more influential
members if indeed they achieve that
South Africa is - and that even though
South Africa voted for the resolution it
opposed regime change soon afterwards so
it changed its mind when it saw regime
change taking place the Arab League
supported the intervention and that was
quite important and was mentioned
Security Council resolution but only the
UAE and Qatar provided money and a
trivial Air Force Air Force contingent
the African Union did condemn Qaddafi
but it also condemned the airstrikes
that followed so the legitimacy the
support is not as deep as it looks it
was a thin authorization behind this
resolution the most important thing is
that the resolution didn't really
authorize the toppling of Colonel
Qaddafi President Obama his strategy was
that they would provide protection okay
and the toppling would take place as
economic sanctions bit on Qaddafi's
regime that is they would pull the
financial plug what was not taken into
account or not known is that Qaddafi was
sitting on bales of $100 bills in
Tripoli and basements full of gold bars
and gold coins he was not gonna run out
of money for an awful long time I'm
wondering where the money is right now
but at any rate he had plenty to run a
civil war so it didn't work it then led
to a series of unpalatable alternatives
if Qaddafi were to stop victimizing
civilians and still retain power while
the rebels maintained their own
territory would partition be an
acceptable solution to the media
under mister Kitab who had been sent by
the Security Council to try to resolve
the crisis that was one question to me
very unpromising the other would be if
the if they could not achieve an
agreement a partition or any other
agreement of the country with the
international community sit by
protecting the Libyan people from
large-scale victimization you know being
bombed by Qaddafi's aircraft while they
fought it out with small arms both sides
shooting each other with pistols and
rifles rather than artillery and
aircraft and that would have been within
the framework of the authorized
resolution to protect the civilian
population of Libya or would the
intervener simply brush aside the
restrictions in UN Security Council
resolution 1973 and wholeheartedly aid
the rebels and topple Qaddafi and of
course we know the answer that was the
third was chosen that is there was
cotter provided funds directly to the
rebels possibly arms the UK in France
but trainers on the ground and there may
have also been American Special Forces
they're serving as bombing spotters and
air coordinators dropped in onto the
ground
again in violation of the arms embargo
and more importantly the air campaign
moved from the targeting of the weapons
that were directly harming Libyan
citizens to the overthrow of the regime
they went after headquarters they went
after communications that went after
depots they went after the Libyan army
and basically smashed it that was not
what most of the states that voted for
the resolution had in mind they were
voting for the protection of civilians
they were voting for an immaculate
intervention one that would take place
under these terms and somehow rather
Qadhafi would would disappear or he
would simply negotiate a solution so
what we now see of what has happened is
that we've had this successful overthrow
of Gaddafi's regime and Qaddafi himself
as of today but many of the states not
all the states not Britain France or the
or the U
who voted for this resolution thought
that they were burned thought that they
were tricked
and so when another r2p potential
situation aroused Syria the French the
British in the background the Americans
tried to get a week resolution but
nonetheless a chapter seven one that
would sanction mr. Assad's regime and
send a message to the rebels that you
know we know you're suffering and it's
illegitimate and a message to Assad that
this is not business as normal so
financial sanctions might be down the
road but this resolution didn't even
have financial sanctions in it only said
it would consider financial sanctions
the Russians and the Chinese negotiated
to water down the resolution when was
presented to the council they've both
vetoed it a very rare double veto in the
Security Council so what is happening
and and this had a good deal support
elsewhere in the UN is the sense that
for some this resolution and r2p which
was going to solve the problem
protection without creating the problem
of imperialism didn't quite succeed the
idea of an immaculate intervention turns
out they should have known to be
unrealistic so when we looked at the
future we can hope that a more let's
call it a mature or small or realistic
understanding enters in is that
immaculate interventions under these
kinds of circumstances would be very
difficult to do and so the Security
Council is going to need to come to the
understanding that that under some
circumstances protection will be regime
change but they also need to have
assurances that if that is the case
that'll be done in a multilateral way it
won't be a rush for oil concessions it
won't be a tip of the balance of power
it will be done in ways that are still
genuinely multilateral or if they think
that's impossible and the imperial
element is too dangerous there'll be a
sense that RTP is really not applicable
in that kind of a situation it just
won't work especially not in the
forceful end of things there still may
be sanctions but that more mature level
of understanding has not yet been
achieved yet and so at the present time
we can celebrate if you will with the
Libyan people their liberation
would not have succeeded without the
bombing by NATO and at the same time we
can commiserate with the Syrians that
the international community can't
express itself on their side so let me
stop here and welcome your questions
floor is open yes please
maybe you should identify yourself if
you would I didn't talk about it but
also rescuing your citizens sometimes
that's that's exactly the framework that
that I want to express that said you
know that's the framework I want to
express exactly as you've summarized it
but I'm also going to say that is that
the world is complicated enough that it
makes a difference exactly how it's done
when we come down into the real detail
some multilateral schemes are totally
exploitable and exploited so it you know
the details really do make a difference
but you've summarized the framework that
I'm arguing for as just as I would have
liked to
I think that no that's not my view is
it's being replaced it's being replaced
by r2p in the sense that you know that
Walter standard is predominantly though
he doesn't phrase it exactly that way
the genocide standard and the thing
that's unique to it is that historically
despite as I mention article a to the
genocide treaty it has been regarded as
a sufficient justification at least in
ethical terms for unilateral action that
is to stop a genocide and that's been
Walters view and it's one that he then
applies to Libya doesn't qualify what
has happened with the r2p standard is
that we've said that things less than
genocide or addition to genocide war
crimes grungees humanity ethnic
cleansing could also justify the
violation of sovereignty but only if and
as a Security Council authorization so
we have broadened or this or lowered the
standard from the high genocide standard
to this lower one but we've raised the a
procedural standard from unilateral to
multilateral and I think that's what's
happening with our TP and as you can
tell from the tonation I think that's a
progressive move if it works yes please
that more difficult than maybe was
initially envisioned by the UN so I just
wanted to ask you what what if it had
happened to be an immaculate
intervention as you would how would your
lecture have been different today and
it's something that's really about
international law or something about
maybe the tactical skill of those doing
the intervening we would be just sitting
around celebrating you know in the sense
that if Qaddafi had you know there were
a lot of defections from his government
the president President Obama was
counting upon the defections plus the
idea that he would never be able to lead
a normal life to produce a surrender and
maybe an exile though there already had
been of course this awkward ICC
indictment that came in between but
there was some hope that this would
happen and indeed among many of the
states who voted for it definitely a
hope that this would be an easy outcome
if that had occurred you know I think
would be celebrating and we would
probably have a very weak sanctions
regime against Assad right now that's
purely hypothetical guessing that that
would have carried through momentum that
would have us waged a lot of concerns of
many g77 members
Russia and China would still have been
very nervous about this but I don't
think if there'd been a groundswell in
the g77 that they would have done a veto
ice-pan if Libby had gone the way they
had hoped it would they would have done
another abstention and that could have
been a vote that going through that
might be a bit idealistic Russia has
very strong interest in the Assad regime
and China has been historically very
very nervous about r2p
though I should mention that both Russia
and China endorsed the principle in
abstract at a 2009 review session on RTP
and they warned you got to be very
careful in application so they they feel
some degree of pressure to join the
global consensus for RTP
but as soon as they had Libya in front
of them they felt and they were worried
about another instance of that they were
they felt very comfortable and no
apologies very strong statements vetoing
the the Syrian resolution it may still
come back
depending upon what happens the
casualties in Syria already are larger
than the casualties in Libya from the
estimates we have you know these things
are always fuzzy so it's a serious issue
yeah no we might this this is not a
happy outcome for the reasons already
suggested and if it's going to if it's
going to be common or mean for them for
our lawyer friends it's not gonna become
customary international law until you
get a lot of practice by a lot of states
all agreeing then you know it's it's law
and it's not otherwise you need a
revisions of the UN Charter and that's
not gonna happen anytime soon so it's
not gonna be a hard law norm for an
awful long time but you're referring I
think to something looser than that and
that's not going to happen until we have
a whole another more set of successes
and this is a very mixed success from
the standpoint of many countries from
Britain France in the u.s. you know they
got a you know a legal legal
intervention that served their ethical
and also political interest but for
other countries this was an alarm bell
that they felt that they were snookered
and so we've got to get more cases that
will give them a sense that it'll be
applied in a way that is in the global
interest rather than just in in the
interest of the great powers and that is
not yet been done yet so I'm I'm I am
now concerned if we if we get at some
point let's say let's say for the poor
Syrians if it continues to get bad as it
has been and gets worse I'm hoping that
there would be some at least
multilateral recognition of the
situation Syria is the last place
anybody would want to send forces into
it's a very different situation as I
understand it from the Libyan one which
despite all the problems was easy but
nonetheless some degree of sanction
would be important for establishing a
more legitimate legal protective
international order but that we don't
know yet and it would take that and then
maybe a few more after that before in
the sense that I think you're referring
to we would have a new not new law but a
new
I see that as less of a problem
again why I haven't been there I don't
have any special access to to any
information but I see that is that was
what you described to me is the problem
of Kosovo that is it was fought at very
high altitude with very severe
consequences
is for innocent Serbs hospitals schools
trains bridges during rush hour the
Chinese embassy all of these things were
blown up under those kinds of
circumstances leading people to
legitimately complain that the NATO
forces weren't willing to take
sufficient risk to save people who
should have been safe this is a little
different situation the first attacks
were on extremely vulnerable air force
and the air suppression was extremely
successful there was a massive us-led
attack on day one that dealt with all of
his air force all of his air air
capacity and air defence radars all of
that was quickly eliminated so there was
very little there was very little
resistance that they could mount unlike
in Serbia where anti-aircraft fire
missiles and others were available which
forced least in NATO's estimation
operated at a high level now
NATO standard practices they don't
operate very low in any case because
there's a potential ground fire and
there were some incidents that we've
read about you know or as a bomb dropped
in the wrong place but as far as I know
and I'd be happy to be corrected we're
talking about very very small numbers of
casualties inflicted by the NATO forces
in Libya just a few mistakes you know
nothing like the Kosovo level so to me
that's less of a problem here
the other issue that was really
important the big problem with Kosovo in
my view was that they had an incredible
threat that is it was made very clear to
Milosevic that this was going to be an
air campaign the the Serbian tanks and
artillery pulled into the forest during
the daytime they came out at night there
was very ineffective air war being being
fought and that was very different
because of the lack of you know forest
cover and things like that in Libya the
tanks and artillery was extremely
vulnerable to us and and other aircraft
so it could be done quite effectively
that regard and the other thing that was
different was in Kosovo the failure to
make a credible ground threat was a
crucial part of dragging this out in
ways that victimized the Serbian
population but here that was not on the
table
Ida neglected to give you a copy of the
Security Council resolution 1973 but
there's a special paragraph that says no
ground forces no occupation that was
violated with covert warriors but not in
any large overt more overt way and so
that was taken off the table for the
sake of legitimacy they didn't want to
have they didn't want to open the door
to another Iraq you know would have an
occupation of the country by by any
means and so that was what I think
something was different but you're right
that as a matter of principle in a
humanitarian intervention there should
be an expectation that soldiers if
they're going if the purpose and the
justification for their action is
humanitarian should be willing to take
risks that are maybe I think larger then
the same risk that they would take in a
purely defensive campaign where they can
assume that the other side is genuinely
hostile even though they're real
non-combatants their soldiers should
always take risks for non-combatants but
I think that there's an argument that
there's a difference in a humanitarian
campaign that would create a higher
standard so I think lies here too and
elsewhere but I just think and I could
be well be wrong that here they did a
much better job on that score than it
did in Kosovo where it really had all
the problems I think are you destroyed
yes please yeah
yeah they're they're overcoming in a
couple ways one is um oh just about all
countries have made it clear that they
hold discretion to apply this I don't
have my copy in front of me but
somewhere to at the bottom of the
paragraph they talk about case-by-case
assessment that's the code language that
this is this may sound like a
responsibility but it's one that they
will undertake discretionary that is
they'll decide or not to decide which
also leads us back into some of the
concerns that Paul was talking about of
how this is applied over time doesn't
acquire legitimacy and I know as a
matter of experience when we couldn't
get a room as I mentioned to it to
present the initial r2p report we went
across the street to millennium Plaza
and then we set up a retreat at
Pocantico the old rockefeller resort on
the Hudson for the Security Council so
we brought the Security Council up there
with Evans and set noon to discuss the
earlier version that I see double IC i
SS report and it was quite interesting
and this was an off-the-record
conversation amongst them completely and
what was interesting is that every
single member thought this is of the
Security Council thought that they could
authorize and r2p action including the
use of force this included Syria who was
a member of the Council at the time that
was very interesting I was very
surprised to hear that no pushback
whatsoever and the Syrians wouldn't
speak until they contacted their capital
back home to see if they could say that
and Assad you know falling back yes or
emailed back whatever he does I don't
know yes and so they all said that they
thought this would authorize them to use
force that was very interesting
so that was unanimous very surprising
Security Council like to have their
power enhance this was one more thing
to it but the other thing was whether
there was a responsibility to act and
that was also absolutely unanimous no
that is they they are unanimous that
this was a license to act and unanimous
that they had no obligation to do so
so there we get back into the world of
politics that we experience regularly
yes it could if it's an if the judgment
the Security Council was that is what is
necessary in order to protect civilians
and they come to that judgment that
would be I it would be a legal
authorization then we would stand back
in question is it necessary you know my
guess is it probably was necessary to
overthrow the Qadhafi regime over the
long run to protect the people of Libya
that is a coalition or a stalemate would
have not produced protection legally I
think that they could have done so
because the Security Council has
extraordinary wide powers you remember
in the UN Charter Article two seven says
that there the UN cannot interfere in
the domestic jurisdiction of any state
except for measures voted under Chapter
seven so this is voted under Chapter
seven it would open up regime change in
the same way they voted in Haiti to kick
out generals address and so they could
do so again in this regard
whether it's wise or not I think yes in
this case probably not many others
to game it right yeah I can see exactly
what you're getting at my view is that I
think it's elegant but but not a big
worry and the reason I don't think it's
a big worry the premises that you're
talking about there are moral hazard
problems you know you will have rebels
saying here's what we need to do in
order to get the UN come rescue us but I
think that in the in the real world any
rebel out there who thinks that China
and Russia are gonna come charging to
support them there's enough uncertainty
in that that this would be a very unwise
position for any rebel to take who
otherwise thought that they couldn't win
you know that they couldn't do it on
their own or that they're forced into a
struggle by the assassin to survive so
if they're really in the terrain of
gaming this and they're assuming that
they can predict what China or Russia
are going to do you know or with the US
France or the u.s. are going to do I
think that's more than enough
uncertainty that we don't need to add in
artificial uncertainty to say to the
council act arbitrarily in order to make
sure that it doesn't get games as a
moral hazard problem I think we can
count upon our irresponsible diplomats
to come come to the floor and protect us
from the danger I think the danger that
logically that you definitely
no that's my that would be my guess I
would not recommend any rebel anywhere
in the world to say that by provoking
you know are crimes against humanity
against their group will get rescued I
would not recommend to anyone of that
yes please I don't want to I don't want
I didn't want to create that I'm very
happy you raised it I don't want to
create a general rule that RTP requires
regime change my comment was
specifically in regard to Libya I can't
imagine the a stable solution where
Qaddafi held
Tripoli and the rebels held then Ghazi
and we would not have you know that
whether we want to recognize them as two
separate countries or whether we would
just say that it stays that way it
doesn't seem it didn't seem to me to be
a stable solution in other circumstances
I would definitely favor a mediation
between the government and the rebels I
think in Syria it may be the only hope
be cut but in the particular case of
Libya I just maybe I don't know enough
about Libya that didn't seem stable to
me because the rebels were already got
the mountains between Tripoli and the
sea Misurata had been
rt1 over cert was definitely Qaddafi but
it was surrounded I did I didn't see a
stable situation that could come out of
there but I'm not a Libya specialist yes
I would hope so if it's not this is not
going to be viable there's gonna have to
be a lot of negotiable solutions as I
would hope for example you know the
problem with Syria is that you know
Christians and Allah whites are not on
the side of these rebels and there are
significant parts of the population so
you know Assad can turn out big
demonstrations for himself that look and
they're based upon people that are
really afraid that the rebels might win
so I'm hoping maybe totally
idealistically it's some kind of a
negotiated solution may come down from
this but I don't know whether it will or
not and in many cases I would hope that
that exactly would be the outcome
from the very beginning the hope was
that Qadhafi would you know cash in his
chips and cut a deal for himself of some
kind of an exile or alternatively that
his regime would collapse so quickly
everybody would get on a plane and fly
to London you know with bags of cash
that he could be quickly seized by the
rebels and but under the view that this
that you're raising that okay you know
what's that going to be you know this is
a regime that had no civil society it
was very very strange Gaddafi's regime
and Ian Martin in New York started
planning because of the view that this
would have to be a longer-term
engagement and he put together with a
small team a proposed peace building
operation that would be authorized under
Chapter 7 by the Security Council that
would step in in a trustee like role
very similar to East Timor or Kosovo and
he I don't know he some parts of this
were leaked and it looked like the
blueprint right out of East Timor or
Kosovo with major components doing
police training judiciary arm training
economic rehabilitation typical election
a couple of years or so down the road
when things would be turned back over to
the Libyans you had this whole plan
worked out and after it leaked there was
huge pushback again this time from both
g77 and more importantly the NTC said
look you know we're gonna win this
battle we're gonna be the government
and so he had to throw the entire thing
out the window and then he's going to
Tripoli maybe maybe he's there by now
with with a blank slate saying what do
you want us to do for you and it's now
going to be a I suspect a very light
operation providing advice to the NTC on
their terms and then the question that
we would have is that going to be
sufficient to help assure of a future
stable viable who knows what Libya you
know the old American nightmare that
most of our new friends rxl Qaeda and
we've been tortured some of their senior
leaders you may have read in the press
the guy who helped conquer most of
Tripoli was al Qaeda that we rendered
tortured he was eventually released and
now he heads up the major militia in
Tripoli and he says he loves America
thank goodness but you can see that this
has a long run question marks attached
to it and those are questions like
you're raising that people are quite
concerned about